y vamos a abrir hoy esta sección de
revista de prensa hablando de las
elecciones en Paraguay porque a pesar de
ser una nación pequeña y bastante
desconocida los medios reflejan hoy en
sus titulares los resultados de los
comicios allí Así que vamos a empezar
con la prensa paraguaya para ello ya
está con nosotros nuestra compañera
Marta Moya Marta feliz inicio de semana
Buenos días Rodrigo muy buenos días
vamos a empezar hablando con el
periódico paraguayo La última hora que
nos trae importada Así es Rodrigo vamos
a empezar con última hora que este lunes
titula paliza de la anr Santiago Peña
vence a Efraín alegre y ya es el nuevo
presidente Santiago Peña candidato de la
asociación nacional republicana También
conocido como el partido Colorado venció
a Efraín alegre con cerca del 43% de los
sufragios 15 puntos más de su competidor
Efraín alegre que estaba liderando una
especie de coalición de Aproximadamente
40 partidos más o menos progresistas que
al final se quedaron sin esperanzas de
Victoria Peña asumirá el cargo el
próximo 15 de agosto y consiguió
imponerse a su opositor a pesar de las
críticas al gobierno de la fractura en
el seno del partido Colorado y además de
todas esas sanciones que ha tenido el
líder del partido Colorado ex presidente
Horacio cartes y además a pesar de unas
encuestas que parecía que indicaban unos
comicios un poquito más ajustados Marta
vamos con ABC color otro medio paraguayo
que es lo que nos cuenta sí Rodri el ABC
color titula este lunes tercera derrota
de frain alegre como candidato opositor
Y es que el candidato de la oposición se
quedó con poco más del 27% de los
sufragios en su tercer intento por
llegar a la presidencia el primero fue
en 2018 perdón el segundo fue en 2018
contra el actual presidente de Mario
abdo Benítez y
primer intento de llegar a la
presidencia de alegre fue en 2013 contra
el ex mandatario Horacio cartes también
del partido Colorado bueno Marta vamos
ahora ya con la prensa internacional el
país el principal periódico en español
que nos cuenta sobre estas elecciones sí
Rodrigo el principal periódico en
español el país destaca ese poderío del
partido Colorado instalado en el
gobierno desde el año 47 solo tuvo un
pequeño break en 2008 Cuando entró en el
poder el ex Obispo Fernando Lugo pero
que cuatro años después lo echaron por
medio de un juicio político en el
parlamento y dice este artículo del país
que aunque las fracturas en el seno del
partido son evidentes ya no se cometen
esos errores sino que todo reman a una
cuando se trata de poner a su candidato
al frente del ejecutivo una tensión
apreciada ayer en las celebraciones tras
la victoria de Peña cuando Horacio
cartes estaba presente en los festejos y
el actual mandatario abdo Benítez solo
se limitó a felicitarlo por Twitter
del exobispo presidente del país que yo
tampoco conocía siempre aprendemos algo
en esta sección vamos ahora con the
Guardia en un medio en inglés que
también se hace eco de estas elecciones
Sí y destaca El guardián que la victoria
de Santiago Peña No pone en tela de
juicio las relaciones entre Paraguay y
Taiwán algo que sí había propuesto el
candidato opositor Efraín alegre que
criticó que no apoyara china Al final
era perjudicial para Paraguay por las
exportaciones de soja o de carne de res
y que al final pues parece que van a
seguir tal como estaba las relaciones
entre Taiwán y Paraguay dado que el
actual presidente electo pues no quiere
poner en tela de juicio esas relaciones
con la isla bueno Marta cerramos ya este
capítulo paraguayo nos vamos hasta
Europa ahora con la cabeza de la Iglesia
Católica que el Papa Francisco
de paz en Ucrania y un plan
Aparentemente secreto han dicho que es
lo que nos ha contado el Papa Francisco
Sí Rodrigo ya parcialmente secreto
porque ayer en ese avión papal de vuelta
de su viaje a Hungría de tres días dijo
a los periodistas que viajaban con él en
el avión que estaba el Vaticano
implicado en una misión secreta para
detener la guerra en Ucrania y de volver
a los niños ucranianos con sus familias
que habían sido deportados a Rusia no
recordemos que el presidente Putin está
implicado y está buscado por las por el
tribunal Penal Internacional por todo
este tema el Papa Francisco no
especificó más sobre el tema pero dijo
que había discutido todo este plan
Secreto con el presidente húngaro Víctor
Urban y también con el líder de la
iglesia ortodoxa de ese país
Bueno me encanta ver al papa entre
bambalinas luchando por la paz en
Ucrania vamos a seguir hablando de
Ucrania porque desde la prensa del país
dicen que hay nerviosismo dentro del
ejército ruso tras los últimos
movimientos ofensivos ucranianos sí
Rodrigo nos referimos a un artículo del
que dice que Rusia está ansiosa por los
últimos acontecimientos
liderados por Ucrania no sin embargo por
supuesto desde Rusia no manifiestan este
tipo de ansiedad y nerviosismo por
ningún lado los movimientos incluirían
el incendio masivo de este fin de semana
en un depósito de petróleo en crimea con
motivo de un ataque supuesto con drones
en sebastopol por parte de Ucrania El
reemplazo de su general de más alto
Rango los rumores de despido de un
Coronel que estaría implicado en la toma
de mariupo el año pasado o la falta de
municiones declarada por el ejército
paramilitar Wagner eso dice la prensa
ucraniana que hay nerviosismo nervios
Desde allí sin embargo desde el kremlin
nos hablan de esa posible contraofensiva
ucraniana que dicen desde un medio afín
al kremlin que se podría dar fuerza por
ella por la central nuclear sí Rodrigo y
nos referimos al con samuscaya Prada y
el periodista que está empotrado con las
tropas del kremlin Alexander cots dice
que el batallón instalado por saporilla
que el ejército ucraniano estaría
pensando liderar esa contraofensiva a
través de los cercos y los bosques que
rodean a toda esta región recordemos que
Rusia se anexó esta región a finales de
septiembre del año pasado una anexión
que no fue reconocida por ningún país y
en las últimas semanas dice el ejército
ruso a este periodista que la presencia
de tropas ucranianas ha aumentado allí y
que están tratando de romper las líneas
defensivas y que por eso podría darse la
contraofensiva Desde allí parece un culo
hebreo en esta contraofensiva que
llevamos esperando muchos meses ya vamos
a ver hasta dónde llega Ucrania con ella
Vamos a cerrar este bloque ahora con un
medio español que tú conoces muy bien
Marta el orden mundial que nos habla
sobre el futuro del grupo Wagner tanto
fuera como dentro de Ucrania sí Rodrigo
y dice que en contra de lo que dice el
propio grupo Wagner según un cintan con
sede en Washington el crimen había
recuperado la confianza en el grupo y
habría empezado a surtir de municiones
otra vez a grupo Wagner Por otra parte
pregojin el líder de Wagner estaría
buscando su salto a la política y
estaría negociando con partidos
opositores a Putin para dar ese salto de
legitimar tanto sus acciones militares
como su discurso una aspiración que se
podría ver mermada sino concluye con
éxito su ofensiva en bahmud que Putin la
espera para antes del 9 de mayo el día
de la victoria en Rusia Rodríguez
como se alarga además la guerra vamos a
cerrar hoy en Francia porque las
expectativas están divi frente a un día
de los trabajadores empañado por la
reforma pensional hacia Rodrigo hemos
destacado un artículo de liberación que
dice que mientras el gobierno Espera que
este 1 de Mayo sea la última resistencia
de las movilizaciones sociales contra la
reforma pensional los sindicatos auguran
una jornada histórica donde se movilicen
millones de franceses para reafirmar esa
contestación a la reforma de las
pensiones de Manuel macron sueñan con
que sea un día histórico no solo en
París sino en todas las regiones
francesas y mañana habrá una reunión de
la intersindical para evaluar Cómo ha
ido la jornada de hoy y para ver cómo
serán los próximos pasos para contestar
esta reforma de las pensiones porque
dicen que no se van a parar aquí pues
Marta Maya Muchas gracias por este
repaso vamos a estar además muy atentos
durante toda la jornada lo que pase ahí
en Francia gracias de nuevo gracias
Rodrigo